yeah I want to see their robot that's
supposed to be here
we're genius man we'll get away with
anything I was just a normal kid for my
world fell apart look at me
white cops can be on to normal school of
the normal life
some kids escape me Wow Lizzy as far as
you're concerned my boyfriend how long
that
they say you run like a girl travel now
we're going to carry on promise don't
expect any spent on stories you throw
like a girl
find life
[Music]
I'm famous
you had your mind be like an email with
me
on this day and I want to fight that
think you're better huh it's okay to be
a kid little Jerry low funny which you
can do when all you have left it pens on
you then well fight like a girl
yeah I thought are you girl coming with
me or what
don't you
[Music]
we call home easy
what are you got in your mouth
[Music]
lots of food right now come on then
careful
you get back in your hole think about
what you did
you want to know why they keep coming
here where the others
once you're hiding I don't sell out
friends
[Music]
you will miss dying not commit crime
[Music]
the secret
my Maker I do
[Music]
[Music]
it has been said through the ages
without sacrifice there could be no
victory to species at war one flesh one
person Optimus Prime has left us one
hundred billion killing damages in the
cosmos
[Music]
you want to know why we keep coming here
[Music]
on a stake and I want to fight them
now who will colliding
now for instance over we're not keep it
up the cake
only one survived
Oh
forgive me
[Music]
[Music]
you
you